uh trump just banned tick tock whoa
really just signed an executive order
saying that tick tock is banned under
the national emergencies act and will
sanction
any company still doing business with
them in 45 minutes breaking i saw that i
saw that in the chat
breaking news i got to check this out
wow the bandwidth to check it
man what a boss we make stuff happen
trump 2020.
you know what i don't need that 30 000
likes
this one's for me oh we're at 28 oh yeah
hey you know what check it out sixty
thousand people are here i love all you
guys you guys are fantastic
so so i i have the story this is
actually from like a half an hour ago
actually
it's been a few minutes yeah yeah check
this out we got this we just pulled it
up from the guardian this is
this is it's it's still technically
breaking i know we're in the twitter era
but
whoa dude this is so wow drop check this
out
trump bans u.s transactions with tick
tocks chinese owned parent company
executive order comes as app faces
scrutiny from u.s lawmakers
and trump administration over national
security concerns so we have a tweet
from hunter walker breaking
president trump just issued an executive
order on addressing the threat posed by
tick tock
it in effect uh it takes effect in 45
days
prohibits any transaction with bike
dance the chinese company that owns tick
tock
and will almost certainly face legal
challenges
the president has just dropped the nuke
and i've been i've been i've been saving
this
i've been saving this story you ready
for this
you want to play games you want to play
games
youtube bans almost 2 600 chinese
channels for influence operations
wow some of the channels posted content
about racial justice protests in the us
we are not playing games trump is not
just banning tick-tock cause he's mad at
some little kids
they're trying to play these stupid
stupid narrative where they're like
trump is just mad because they pranked
his of his rally
no no trump is concerned that tick tock
has been taking data and giving it to
the communist party of china
yep and you were mentioning this earlier
about yeah i'll say it i was
so i was watching this documentary on uh
surveillance
and chinese companies have been building
these
facial recognition software um
devices basically and selling them all
across the world
the eu uses them uh africa uses them
i mean who knows how many um
devices that are on this planet use them
but tick tock
if you think about what that is in their
in everybody's smartphone that got
facial recognition now
they've got all this information now
they they we know that they've been
taking information they're like oh they
can look at your stuff it's like yeah
they can also look at your face
and document that go ahead i got i got
to tell you guys how much more
how much worse tic toc is than you
realize did you know
that you have a facebook profile now of
course many people are probably saying
of course i do and many people are
saying no i don't never signed up no no
quite literally all of you do
whether you signed up or you didn't
facebook has something called
shadow profiles let me let me explain to
you the danger of tick tock and why
this i'm gonna i'm defer to the experts
but very well may be necessary
let's say you have your phone as adam
mentioned facial record facial
recognition first and foremost
you pop open the tic-tac app and you're
filming yourself and you're making duck
face or whatever right
now they know your name your email your
password and what your face looks like
and china has hacked us industry in the
past now your password which most people
reuse everywhere they can access
everything about you they know your name
they know your birthday probably if you
signed up and put in your birthday
they have your email they can log into
your email but it gets better than that
they have access to your contact lists
now
i'm not going to make allegations
against tick tock if i don't if i can't
prove it
i don't know if tick tock takes your
mobile list the way facebook does
but let me tell you what facebook does
let's say adam never signs up for
facebook
and i have on my phone facebook app in
my at my contact list of my phone
numbers
i have adam kriegler it's got his phone
number when you open the app it says
allow us to look at your contact list to
find your friends
and everybody says yes facebook takes
that list and takes adam kriegler puts
his phone number down
the best part here's the best part now
they have a profile for adam with just
his phone number but hold on
adam's sister posted a photo saying me
with my with my brother adam
now they add that to his profile a photo
of him
facebook builds shadow profiles of
people because people around you share
data
that they that the third party never
agreed to share now think about where
that goes with tick tock
if tic tac is on your phone and they've
been accused of spying and stealing
background
contacts yeah they do take your contacts
think about this man
they've got your contact list they know
who your mom is they know your dad now
they know your mom guess what
they can pull up her information find
her made name boom they got your bank
account
it's that easy they're gonna pull up
everything on everybody and have access
to all this information
that's why the ban on tick tock was
considered that's why it's serious
it has nothing to do with trump's thin
skin or some woman mocking him
on online it has everything to do with
the fact that first of all
we're mad enough that facebook is is
basically spying on us in
effect and creating shadow profiles for
people who never signed up
now the last thing i want is facebook to
do it let alone the communist party of
china
yeah so this is why a ban on tick tock
is
legit now i'm not going to pretend to
know the inner workings of all of this
but i can tell you
that we know big tech spies on us
alexandria ocasio-cortez herself slammed
big tech companies
for surveillance and for spying and i
applauded her for doing so
i and now is she going to come out and
be in support of this i'd really doubt
it
i don't i really doubt it i doubt it too
but tick tock is worse
why is it that when big tech is
censoring
american citizens the aclu mums the word
freepress.net mum's the word but as soon
as trump talks about banning tick-tock
the aclu steps up and says that would be
a violation of human rights
yeah because all these companies and
non-profits are in it for
china yes they are so you ever you ever
notice you're talking with a friend of
yours about uh
you know what i haven't had in a while
portillo's hot dogs and then all of a
sudden boom there's ads on your computer
think about that and think about what
happens when we're talking about
escalating conflict between china
china's talking about you know doing
they're doing air raid drills
there's a real fear of conflict emerging
and now they know everything about you
let me make it worse for you what do you
think what do you think would happen in
this country
once tick-tock grants access listen all
these young people
all their information now your password
now it gets better what can what if you
logged into tiktok using a different app
like facebook or google
let's say you log into tiktok you use
your email address and your password and
then they get access to your phone to
your email to everything
and then they publish all of your
private information you want to talk
about real war and disruption of
economies
how would you feel okay let's see jen's
ears i don't know how many are watching
what would you do if tomorrow all of
your private messages and private photos
were published on the internet for
anyone to see
you would not be happy nobody would
absolutely not
and all this information can easily be
stolen and if you have a foreign
adversary of this country stealing that
data
you should not be surprised if they use
it and they use it to disrupt our
economy because i tell you this man
the biggest economic disruption i could
i could think of is if
everyone's internet history and private
messages became public
all of a sudden co-workers would hate
each other bosses would get fired
overnight
everybody would be found out to be
racist or sexist or bigoted
everybody would know everything and it
would cause absolute
bedlam more importantly they can target
um i don't know nuisances to them
let's say you're somebody who is using
tic tac and you're speaking out against
the atrocities in china like the weaker
muslim crisis
the genocide now they're going to be
like let's publish their private
information destroy their life there it
is
they got rid of a nuisance so i'll tell
you what man
in 45 days we'll see how this plays out
because it is it is it is not a
guarantee
and then my phone just turned on that
was creepy oh yeah yeah my phone just
went
started recording my voice what yeah
that was creepy that is creepy
for real it just so i it just turned on
it started
words started popping up so i had to
turn it off
okay they're coming for me i i i do not
have tik tok
i don't either i do not so
here here's here's the one thing i will
say
we got a big tech problem absolutely we
were just ragging on twitter for
shutting down the president
for all the censorship stuff so tick
tock is a foreign adversary i think we
should absolutely call it out
definitely i defer to the experts on
this one but i'll tell you this man if
we know what facebook does
and that's only what we what we know now
i'd only want to think about what
tick-tock is doing
because that data is getting stolen
apparently it was stealing like
clipboard data yeah and data from other
apps
wow yeah so and who knows what those
other apps
actually had access to themselves yeah
imagine
imagine some some dumb person pulling up
that incognito mode and looking at some
nasty photos and
you know having a good time and then
tick doc knows oh man dude
dog knows the chinese xi yeah
so uh we talked about this last time a
picture of mark zuckerberg
you know coming up over a wall because
facebook facebook literally does know
when you poop
yep i'm not it's not this is not a joke
they do
uh okay okay i gotta be careful for
legal reasons my understanding based on
an article i read on the internet
whether it's true or not but i will say
this i wouldn't be surprised if xi
jinping knows when you poop
huh yeah yeah there's there's there it
is
someone sent us this board i love it
this is an actual depiction
of him looking at you while you poop
just like that there was a story i read
that says facebook knows
when you're moving because of location
tracking
and they know what's around you and they
can predict your behavior and they can
also read your messages
so they know if you're talking about
food and if you're talking about you
know i gotta run to the bathroom so they
can really predict when you're gonna go
or when you are you know in the john
yep now it's bad enough mark zuckerberg
knows this stuff
i'm not i wouldn't want xi jinping you
know that's that's
no way worse definitely not there's no
accountability for china so to get to
get a bit serious
if facebook really did cross the line we
as american citizens could
have some kind of accountability i know
it's not perfect because facebook gets
away with a lot
but if it was communist china we'd sit
back and
complain about it that's about it yeah
this is crazy it's not like we're
getting in a ground the story
yeah i don't think so i don't think so i
think i think
i think the war we're going to see is
going to be designed for the information
age
we have not had a great war in the
information age yeah
so there was something really
interesting happened a few years ago
it was the first time we saw a footage
from both sides of a conflict
i think it was in syria you had a tank
with a gopro mounted on it
and it was firing at two guys also with
gopros mounted and both
both sets of the footage got uploaded
later and then a news organization like
a news non-profit found both
both clips yeah and put them together
and they were like
that's kind of crazy yeah to see from
both perspectives of the conflict so
this is like one of the first
this was one of the first big moves of
the information age warfare
another one which is kind of horrifying
and hilarious
is when the al-qasam brigades in
palestine were firing missiles into
israel
and israel was you know striking back
and they were having a flame war on
twitter
wow so like yeah the idf was like we
will crush you you terrorists and they
were like we will never rest we're
coming for and they're like tweeting at
each other
so like we're watching these guys tweet
each other and like literally try and
blow each other up
wow you should focus the important
factor here is that you need to
understand weapons of war will be
designed for information warfare
if somebody sees a video of like a u.s
ship doing something
or a big explosion or a big explosion
and they're and they're gonna you know
they're gonna be like look that country
did it it's gonna be bad on the
international stage
which means information age warfare will
need to be as as
as subversive as possible or a showy
show we yes to shock and awe but they
can't it depends on who they want to
know
you know who's doing what right so if
they want you to know they're going to
come for you
they it wouldn't be a random explosion
it would be like a gigantic american
flag
followed by like a bunch of lasers so
like that's us
you know but i think because there's a
concern about looking
oppressive or like looking looking look
no matter what you do whether it's
defensive or not blowing up
stuff makes you look bad we're going to
see really weird things there's going to
be stealth there's going to be
you know just subversive tactics
suitcase nukes whatever
whatever they can do to take things out
without anyone knowing they were there
yep
and the other thing too is we won't be
able to prove it they'll make it look
like a lightning strike they'll make it
look like a natural disaster
that's the way they have to play it i
wonder what technologies they're
developing today yeah who knows
at any rate tick tock yeah has been
nuked
yes i guess we'll see what happens man
good riddance yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you